ça fait deux ans que nous sommes en
négociation avec amazon pour implanter
une plateforme de logistique sur leurs
parcs de fontaine c'est 300 emplois qui
vont être créés dans une période un peu
difficile avec les restructurations de
general electric
ce n'est que s'élancent nouvelle pour le
territoire de belfort 80 emplois en cdi
231 induit le maire de belfort peut être
satisfait jusqu'au bout il aura gardé le
secret
la technique d'implantation amazon a
bien été respectée il y a 6 mois
il affirmait encore n'être au courant de
rien par cette action le prévu damas
donne à ce jour sur le territoire de
belfort
amazon n'est pas propriétaire de ses
bâtiments nous sommes locataires donc
lille avançons avec des partenaires qui
avance sur des permis de construire dans
diverses régions et nous confirmons
notre présence à l'issue des permis de
construire à fontaine le design amazon
n'est pas encore apposé sur les façades
mais c'est bien le 29e site logistique
du géant qui est en cours de
construction
mauvaise nouvelle pour les opposants au
projet ça m'inspire pas grand chose
d'autre qu'à une remarque générale
je n'ai jamais obtenu l'aveu du
président de l'agglomération de belfort
dans ce dossier j'ai fini par apporter
les preuves
cette implantation a totalement échappé
au débat public et c'est un scandale
absolu pour la démocratie dans laquelle
nous vivons
opacité du dossier impact écologique et
travaux d'aménagement l'arrivée du géant
un coût pour les opposants si on
construit des contournements des routes
pour faciliter la desserte ici et puis
désengorger les petits villages
ça coûte de l'argent c'est par amazon
qui va payer ça c'est bien un coût pour
la collectivité qui a quand même un
certain nombre de financements publics
qu'ils partiront sur ce dossier là on
les chiffres approximativement donc à
dix millions dix millions d'euros sur un
total de 200 millions ca présente pas
mal sans aucune concertation avec les
citoyens
le site de livraison de proximité dit du
dernier kilomètre doit ouvrir à
l'automne